dieses video oder dislike das video also
nur damit gleich viele likes und des
lecks da sind hey bist du dumm luca ich
erkläre ich das mal und bleibt auf jeden
fall bis zum ende dran weil ihr könnt
noch sonnen iphone sieben gewinnen aber
gut gefangen bin nichts du dich meine
youtube trends gehe sehe ich türkische
musik videos irgendwelche bundeswehr
blog irgendwelche sich rein gekauften
wie dir und die frage die sich jetzt
derzeit jeder youtuber irgendwie stellt
es einen versatz muss sich als creator
tun um in die trends zu kommen und jetzt
ist in letzter zeit vermehrt das gerücht
umgegangen das ist integration also dass
youtube will das so viel wie möglich um
ein video herum passiert deswegen machen
wir alle zusammen jetzt einfach mal ein
experiment und zwar versuchen wir jetzt
die like anzahl gleich zu halten wie die
dislike anzahl das heißt quasi übersetzt
das wenn ihr das video gerade schaut und
das video hat irgendwie 1100 likes aber
1099 sitz likes dann dislike dir das
video einfach damit das immer gleich
viel ist also ich bin dabei ich habe
videos gesehen vom beispielsweise abwehr
gesagt hat schaffen wir 500.000 aufrufe
cherry pie hat das schon so aufgemacht
wo immer gesagt hat josha frey millionen
likes schaffen eine million dislike
blabla ich will das ganze einfach so
machen dass wir gleich viel haben also
ihr könnt doch einfach gar nicht leid
und gar nicht das leicht bleibt es
vielleicht auch gleich aber ich versuche
es einfach irgendwie hinzukriegen fans
negativ das erste mal vor weihnachten
noch ne also ich hoffe ihr ab und
schönes fest und verbringen zeit mit der
familie und aus diesem grund werde ich
auch heute ein iphone
klose der ist voll cool ist das neue in
mattschwarzen wenn ihr dieses iphone
sieben gewinnen wollt müsst ihr nur drei
sachen machen und zwar erstens meinen
kanal abonnieren
[Musik]
zweitens diesem video ein like oder
einen dislike geben also einfach nur
damit wir wieder experiment und so genau
und drittens einfach irgendein kommentar
und rein spam wie ich euch erreichen
kann als beispielsweise euren instagram
oder euren twitter-namen oder so und da
könnt ihr wirklich so viele kommentare
schreiben wir wollen wir können locker
jeder irgendwie 100 200 mal die gleichen
kommentar schreiben oder so ich möchte
einfach interaktionen weil auf dieses
video möchte sehen ob es damit in die
trends kommt weil da war ich jetzt auch
schon sehr lange nicht mehr drin
das war quasi alles was ich wirklich in
diesem video heute sagen wollte als ich
möchte einfach dieses experiment mit
euch machen ob wir es hinkriegen die
like anzahl genauso groß sein wie die
dislike anzahl und nochmal
nachträgliches weihnachtsgeschenk an
euch also wie gesagt total abonnieren
kommentar schreiben irgend eine
bewertung abgeben
das werde ich in einer woche auflösen
und jetzt finden wir erst mal den
gewinner raus der letzte woche die
kamera gewonnen hat die website ist
gerade alle kommentare durchgegangen das
heißt randomly pickel winner und
gewonnen hat der user franziska schlagen
franziska schlagen raul auf install an
franziska punkt 2030 werde ich
anschreiben und du hast die kamera
gerade ja herzlichen glückwunsch
franziska ich hoffe du hast viel spaß
mit der kamera das ist aber auch schon
vom video
ich würde mich freuen wie schon gesagt
wenn ihr ein like oder dislike geben
könnte damit das video irgendwie gleich
gehalten wird um spams hin was in die
kommentare